When you find yourselves alongside
our sailors and soldiers in the battle
fields and combat of 1943 and 1944,
you will feel that we are your worthy
brothers in arms and you will know that
we shall never die nor weaken, but march
with you into any quarter of the world
that may be necessary to establish the
reign of justice and the law among men.
We do not need scholars or politicians
like Lord John Russell of whom Queen
Victoria remarked, he would be a better
man if he knew a third subject, but he
was interested in nothing but the
constitution of 1688 and himself. What we
need are men who can ride easily over
broad fields of knowledge and recognize
the mutual dependence of our two worlds.
"Don't teach my boy poetry," an English
mother recently wrote the Provost of
Herald. "Don't teach my boy poetry, he's
going to stand for Parliament. " Well
perhaps she was right, but if more
politicians knew poetry and more poets
knew politics, I am convinced the world
would be a little place in which to live
on this Commencement Day of 1956.
I have no gold and silver to give to the
American people, but I give my sisters
and I hope together with them, you will
go in search, like Mary, go in haste to
find the poor and if you find them, if
you come to know them, you will love them.
And if you love them, you will do something
for them. The poor you may have right
in to your own family.
I learned a lot here at Harvard about new
ideas and economics and politics. I got
great exposure to the advances we made in
the sciences, but humanity's greatest
advances are not in its discoveries, but in
how those discoveries are applied to
reduce inequity, whether through
democracy, strong public education,
quality health care, our broad economic opportunity,
reducing inequity is the highest human achievement.
If you choose to use your
status and influence to raise your voice
on behalf of those who have no voice, if
you choose to identify not only with the
powerful but with the powerless, if you
retain the ability to imagine yourself
into the lives of those who do not have
your advantages, then it will not only be
your proud families who celebrate your
existence, but thousands and millions of
people whose reality you have helped
change. We do not need magic to transform
our world. We carry all the power we need
inside ourselves already, we have the
power to imagine better.